representa una doble derrota política
para el mandatario peruano Porque tanto
el tribunal constitucional como el
congreso de este país le dijeron a Pedro
Castillo que su gobierno no puede
modificar una ley porque eso es trabajo
exclusivo del parlamento qué es lo que
había sucedido la mesa directiva del
Congreso de Perú declaró inadmisible la
cuestión de confianza planteada hace una
semana por el hasta ayer Primer Ministro
al nivel Torres para modificar la ley
del referéndum muchos legisladores
consideran que la medida Busca en el
fondo impulsar un referéndum para
modificar la Constitución peruana y esto
a su vez permitiese a Pedro Castillo
evadir a la justicia por las seis
acusaciones que tiene en su contra por
presunta corrupción y lo legisladores
también temen que al modificarse de la
Carta Magna peruana Pedro Castillo
podría intentar quedarse más de los
cinco años establecidos por la
Constitución Política de este país pues
bien en este hecho que entre el poder
legislativo y el poder ejecutivo al ser
declarada inadmisible la cuestión de
confianza Aníbal Torres renunció y a
Pedro Castillo no le quedó más remedio
que aceptar la derrota y la renuncia de
su Primer Ministro